faites vous confiance à jean castex et
gérald darmanin pour restaurer
l'autorité de l'état ça c'est la
première question qu'on vous pose sur
twitter on vous la pose parce que le
premier ministre et ministre de
l'intérieur vous êtes sévère je vois
dans vos réponses
on fait une visite surprise ce matin à
dijon dans le quartier dégrisé théâtre
d'affrontements il y a quinze jours
entre tchétchène et maghrébins le chef
du gouvernement a d'abord pris la
défense des policiers dans une
discussion était pris à partie par un
habitant
les accusés ce ne sont plus certainement
pas les forces de sécurité et forces de
l'ordre voient elles ont fait leur
travail et toutes celles et ceux qui ont
concouru à ces désordres doivent être
punis mais on se trompe pas de cause
monsieur effectué il ya des gens qui
sont venus ici ils sont venus ici
souvent extérieurs en quartier ils sont
également totalement et qui sont venus
faire des actes inadmissibles
là dessus on est absolument intraitable
alors on sera intraitable en tous les
cas le premier ministre a tenu à ne pas
rester sur des discours il a annoncé une
mesure on les écoute
c'est donc un message je l'assumé le
revendique de grande fermeté que je suis
venu porter ici j'ai d'ailleurs pour ne
pas rester parole une belle déclaration
a sorti venus sur proposition de
monsieur le ministre de l' annonce de la
création de 20 postes de policiers
supplémentaires qui seront affectés dès
le mois de septembre
ici à dijon jean sainte marie jouer que
vous riez pendant que vous écoutez jean
castex pourtant il ya des actes des
actes concrets
oui non je ris parce que je suis devenu
une bonne humeur naturelle mais des
actes concrets ces dépenses il s'agit de
créer des postes de policiers alors
qu'on est confronté à cette occasion là
à l'émergence à la public d'armes de
guerre ça n'a plus rien à voir si vous
voulez avec un problème de délinquance
comme on peut avoir dans toute la france
d'ailleurs c'est dijon oui bien sûr donc
là si vous voulez il faut effectivement
c'est assez curieux parce qu'à ce moment
là si on né sait plus du tout la même
chose en réalité s'il ya effectivement
des filières si on aimerait savoir ce
que les français on est très traumatisés
par sa part le spectacle dijon c'est à
dire c'est un spectacle de proto guerre
civile en réalité hier ça valide des
récits ou des écrits que l'on qualifie
généralement d'extrême droite mais qui
paraissait comme une espèce de dystopie
engagé et qui aujourd'hui sont illustrés
par des vidéos on voit des gens qui
brandissent des armes
vous avez vu c'est ces slogans tagués
sur les murs de dijon ses marques et
vive poutine vive la russie parce que en
quelque sorte les maghrébins règlent
leurs comptes avec les tchétchènes
présent été vu la russie ces scènes qui
était surréaliste qui ne sont pas très
drôle en réalité qui annonce
effectivement le fait qu' on peut avoir
des armes de guerre brandis dans y
compris dans des villes réputées
tranquille comme dijon aux gens toute
objectivité on s'était habitués y
compris il ya très longtemps emmené 70
savoir des armes de
guère brandis dans des conférences de
presse clandestine en corse se fait plus
et aux pays bas et là on voit des choses
qui sont affectés tout à fait sidérante
est assez terrifiante par rapport à la
part rapport pour les français et encore
une fois c'est un spectacle de
pré-guerre civile
en effet nous avons tous étaient très
choqués par ce qui s'est passé à dijon
par ces images assez invraisemblable que
nous avons vu mais nous avons aussi
étaient tous très choqués par l'inaction
de l'état dans les heures qui ont suivi
ce c'est fait et ce qui est intéressant
dans ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a assisté aujourd'hui à un
exercice de communication politique
assez rare c'est à dire que le
gouvernement le premier ministre le
ministre d'intérieur vent à dijon alors
qu'il n'ya aucune actualité à dijon il
ne se passe rien ils sont ils vont à
dijon pourquoi pour réécrire une
histoire il faut modifier le récit de la
première version la première version
ce sont des scènes d'une très grande
violence c'est une inaction de l'état
semble complètement tétanisés et les
gens ne comprennent pas pourquoi il n'y
a pas une une réaction massive des
descentes des perquisitions des
arrestations
on comprend pas et donc évidemment
aujourd'hui un mois après le
gouvernement ne veut pas rester sur 7
sur cette idée là c'est sur cette
installation encore c'est un acte de
communication politique parce que
franchement tout ça pour dire quoi pour
dire on va vous donner 20 policiers en
plus vingt policiers qui ont dû être
certainement pris ailleurs quelque part
qui vont sans doute manqué dans un autre
commissariat ou dans un autre territoire
voyez c'est que là le gouvernement il
est dans une réécriture de l'histoire
parce qu'il a conscience que ce qui
s'est passé à dijon a choqué une
énormément de gens mais les a choqués
surtout par la perception d'un état
incapable de réagir à une telle
situation on peut aller beaucoup plus
loin on peut aller beaucoup plus loin
encore une fois il s'agit d'armes de
guerre moi j'ai cru quand je les ai vu
apparaître sur les vidéos jets d'eau sur
internet et monique guillon j'ai cru
même c'était d'armes factices sinon
c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs dans un
certain dans un premier temps entre les
cailloux des vérifications pour le soc
pour voir si c'était pas d un peu
raciste nous a pas rassurés apparemment
c'est pas le cas donc effectivement
c'est que ce qui est dit depuis
longtemps sur les armes
circule dans les cités etc semblent
valider et c'était encore plus étonnant
c'est la décontraction des personnes qui
passent qui ce film et qui brandissent
ses armes
c'est ahurissant alors bon ils sont
vaguement masques et encore pas tous
enfin bref tout va bien et là qu'est ce
qu'on a on n'a pas grand chose comme
réaction ensuite on une réaction qui se
veut très ferme qui est d'ailleurs un
peu surjouée d'ailleurs un prêt ministre
n'a pas une réaction très ferme il dit
je suis venu pour émettre un message de
fermeté
si l'objet de le dire c'est que c'est
absolument évident et d'autres plus que
allons sur les images des images
récentes
moi j'ai vu y compris parce que j'étais
allé pour le figaro magazine vous en
souvenez sur les champs-elysées et à
l'arc de triomphe c'était donc le 1er
décembre 2018 moi j'ai vu des blindés
légers dans les rues de paris et
d'ailleurs ça va être annoncée par le
premier ministre de l'époque par edouard
philippe
tout cela il sait très fier de 4
monsieur castetner de 10 à dire les
blindés sont entrés en paris s'était
montré à la télévision le matin pour
intimider les manifestants très
probablement et on a fait rentrer pour
la première fois depuis très longtemps
des blindés légers de gendarmerie dans
paris contre qui contre un mouvement
social contre des gens qui pour
l'essentiel
suivent les règles du jeu qui payent
leurs impôts etc qui sont plénier
simplement d'en payer trop je dis pas
que toutes les actions qui ont été
menées par les gilets jaunes sont
légitimes mais malgré tout face au jeu
les jaune ça face au mouvement social
on a eu très peu ou très peu soutenu par
la gauche à l'époque d'ailleurs mais on
a eu effectivement des blindés légers on
a une démonstration de force incroyable
fasse effectivement à une démonstration
d'armes de guerre et militaires etc
mais on n'a pas grand chose et ça se
passe à dijon mais ça se passe presque
toujours regarder la riposte de l'état
la civette et d'état par rapport au
monde social en général et au général en
particulier et par rapport à ce qui se
passe par rapport à d'autres populations
vous verrez que dans un cas vous avez
une extrême sévérité
une extrême démonstration de force dans
l'autre cas vous avez une extrême
mansuétude j'interprète surtout le
déplacement du premier ministre à dijon
ce matin comme un message politique
c'est à dire si on doutait un tant soit
peu que le cap fixé par le président de
la république à ce gouvernement est un
cap résolument à droite là les doutes ne
sont absolument plus permis et là
le premier ministre va dijon pour dire
aux français pour dire aux français
c'est un gouvernement de droite et on va
remettre au centre de on va remettre en
tête de nos actions la question de la
sécurité
d'ailleurs il faut quand même remarquer
que malgré les événements de dijon les
questions sécuritaires ne sont pas dans
le dans le top dans le top 5 des
préoccupations des français
les six ici non non non non non non
libéré par les mets toutes les études
d'opinion font apparaître quoi les
dernières études d'opinion les
préoccupations des français les trois
premières
c'est la santé c'est l'emploi et c'est
l'écologie
ce sont les trois premières
préoccupations et d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs c'est ses préoccupations là
elles ont pesé lourd
elles ont pesé lourd dans le
comportement pour ceux qui sont allés
voter dans le comportement aux élections
et le stockage
je suis sidéré par ce que j'entends
parce que qu'est-ce qui est aussi dernir
que là que c'est une politique de droite
que de vouloir maintenir à tonalité du
fassent un don dans les cités les
quartiers populaires n'ont pas le diable
solutions optiques de gauche serait de
l'emploi du talent à voir le relais à la
libre dans l'angle mais vous ne
connaissez absolument rien à ce que je
pense là dessus pour pouvoir dire
quelque chose comme ça non bien les
études que j'ai fait dans les banlieues
populaires devraient être des mairies
communistes deuil non mais c'est pas ça
que je vous dis les gens réclament avant
tout ailleurs souvent les élus mais en
tout cas les électeurs les citoyens
réclament avant tout une présence
policière plus alors si vous voulez
aller sur ce terrain je vous le dis la
sécurité c'est la première des libertés
pour les français en particulier dans
les quartiers populaires en particulier
dans les quartiers populaires donc là
dessus c'est pas sur ce terrain là que
vous aller m'entraîner dans un discours
hiroshi d'autres éléments de voix c'est
une invention de gauge le droit de
pardon le message écoliers - somme à des
populaires le sens du déplacement ce
matin du premier ministre c'est de
montrer que le cap fixé au gouvernement
est un gouvernement de droite et que le
cap
si si bien sûr que c'est ça c'est un
message qui est qui est destiné et quand
on veut montrer un message de droite
qu'est ce qu'on fait on va d'abord sur
la question de la sécurité il a pas
parlé
rassurez-vous s'attendait au vu des
images que l'on voit très peu
convaincante
c'est quoi l'actualité aujourd'hui
l'actualité aujourd'hui
les licenciements chez nokia c'est les
licenciements les suppressions d'emplois
chez renault c'est les suppressions
d'emplois chez airbus
il en a pas parlé de ça ce moment
l'actualité 7-6 6-6 un brave homme un
brave homme qui se sent métier de pour
un salaire modeste comme conducteur de
bus a été massacrée par des délinquants
absolue oui mais avec une réaction de la
gauche extrêmement faible la gauche qui
s'étaient mobilisés place de la
république pour une cause que l'on peut
juger relativement contestable je parle
de la sphère traoré et bien cette gauche
là ne se mobilise pas actuellement et à
bayonne ce sont 6000 personnes qui l'ont
fait en dehors des organisations et
aucun leader de gauche n'a cru
nécessaire de se déplacer
il s'agit encore une fois d'un chauffeur
de bus qui fait partie de votre
électorat potentiel qui veut venir qui
fait partie à c'est un brave homme
non mais moi je n'ai aucun électorat et
en plus pas personnellement je ressens
une très grande compassion pour cet
homme qui il est arrivé la pire des
choses vous l'admettrez que la gauche
institutionnelle se mobilise pas non
mais c'est en effet mobiliser pour une
cause que l'on jugera moi je suis
d'ailleurs à je ne sais pas je porte
parole de la gauche j'en parle à minima
parce que je sais que ces gens là ont la
dégaine judiciaire facile mais c'est une
cause que l'on peut juger contestable ou
regretterez non mais ce que je reconnais
surtout c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
préoccupations qui sont exprimées par
les français et pour le moment c'est à
dire les préoccupations majeures qui
sont exprimés c'est que la crise
sanitaire
elle est en train de provoquer une crise
sociale de très grande ampleur
il y à des groupes il y à des groupes
qui utilisent la crise pour accélérer un
certain nombre de via furent de
restructuration et met des milliers de
gens à la porte nous sommes des sas et
c'est une angoisse pour pour nos
compatriotes
et aujourd'hui le gouvernement n'est pas
du tout alors d'accord mais cet enjeu
voilà les traits de faire une remarque
quand même que par rapport à ce que
disait dieu l'homme sainte marie on peut
être de gauche avant dé sur sa sécurité
et on peut être de droite également
avoir discours sur la sécurité
ce que disait je voudrais revenir sur
l'histoire de la ferme de l'autorité de
l'état et est effectivement donc tout
l'enjeu qu'il ya autour
cet internaute et je salue les
internautes du figaro
nicky magma kelly rowland l'entarteur et
babineau qui dit qu'il est d'accord avec
jude smadja il y a eu un grand
dysfonctionnement de l'état régalien à
dijon l'entarteur qui nous dit les
malfrats n'ont rien à craindre cela va
continuer je crains et rolland qui dit
c'est de la com ou et la fermeté où est
le changement petit lui va va plus loin
vous êtes d'accord il sera difficile de
faire pire que castaner mais reconquérir
la confiance des forces de l'ordre sera
très compliqué au regard des attaques
inadmissibles partait à leur égard par
le précédent locataire de la place
beauvau donc christophe castaner ce lien
de confiance est par trop abîmé et
d'arbanats n'a pas de carrure pour la
rétablir n'est pas pascouau sarkozy qui
veut jérôme sainte marie
ce qui est vrai c'est que la sécurité
cannes dans l'esprit des gens c'est
quelque chose qui est assimilé à des
hommes de droite
alors faut être très prudent là dessus
parce que on met sous le même nom
d'autorité des choses très différentes
il ya la sécurité par rapport à la
délinquance
de ce point de vue là les derniers
chiffres sont catastrophiques
donc le bilan monsieur castaner n'est
très mauvais entame sécurité si j'en
crois ce qu'on rit dans le figaro en
tout cas est à croire qu ils enfileront
et donc voilà et donc et puis après il
ya la sonorité par rapport aux
mouvements sociaux par rapport aux
manifestations de rue et là monsieur
castaner qui a fait plaisir à une partie
d'ailleurs de gens qui ont voté pour
françois fillon qui ensuite sont allés
voter pour la liste l'oiseau satisfait
de l'action des forces de l'ordre très
véhémente aux élections européennes en
2009 face aux actions des forces de
l'ordre face à 2019 et là monsieur
kastner a fait quelque chose
d'extrêmement comment dirais-je pénible
pour les forces de l'ordre c'est qui les
a incités en fait allé très au-delà de
ce qui est habituel dans un cadre
implique un avoir un usage très offensif
notamment des célèbres lbd à
l'utilisation des lbc face au génie john
était incroyablement plus importante que
pendant 20 ans en banlieue et donc face
à des manifestants il ya eu
effectivement à ce type de manifestants
il ya eu un usage que l'on peut juger
disproportionné de la force et monsieur
castaner a déclaré les couvrir et je
crois et je sais d'ailleurs que pas mal
de supérieur de la police et la
gendarmerie étaient tout à fait
embarrassé par cela parce qu'ils ont
besoin de tenir leurs hommes
dans des situations difficiles et si
vous avez un gouvernement derrière qui
est extrêmement laxiste extrêmement
permissif par rapport à l' usage
disproportionné de la force
sa place les les autorités de la police
la gendarmerie dans une position
délicate or en plus la promesse n'est
pas tenue parce que actuellement vous
avez des actions en justice qui sont
menées contre les gendarmes et policiers
qui se sentent et on se met à leur place
c'est compréhensible
lâché par l'autorité politique qui leur
a dit allez-y on vous couvre mais qui en
fait ne couvre pas tant que cela donc
les policiers sont perdants des gens
dans les journalistes ayant été faste
pour sans vie dans le cadre de violences
en tous les cas de violence supposée
d'accusations de violences dans le cadre
de la répression du mouvement des jeunes
qui vont l'être encore et qui vont
l'être davantage
et là monsieur castaner qui
effectivement les avaient incités à un
usage très libre on va dire de leurs
armes
eh bien monsieur questionnaire sera pas
là pour les protéger et d'ailleurs il
n'a certainement pas l'intention
aujourd'hui dans les banlieues que je
connais bien depuis longtemps
les policiers font un travail très
difficile très difficile
ils font un travail ils sont confrontés
à quoi ils sont confrontés
essentiellement à une délinquance qui se
structure autour du trafic de drogue
autour des rodéos qui empoisonnent la
vie des gens dans les quartiers des
rodéos moto autour des occupations de
halls d'immeubles et je peux vous
assurer que sur ces questions là qu'ils
sont le quotidien de l'action de la
police mais c'est très très très
compliqué d'intervenir de d'appréhender
de déférer de dresser des procès-verbaux
et en plus quand on a le sentiment qu'il
n'ya pas de doctrine et que finalement
on se débrouille comme on peut qu' il
n'y a pas deux il n'ya pas
d'orientations claires que les souvent
les équipages sur le terrain ils ne sont
pas encadrées il ya un énorme problème
aujourd'hui dont très peu de gens
parlent c'est que dans les commissariats
de police en particulier dans la
banlieue parisienne il ya une pénurie
d'officiers de personnels d'encadrement
qui est qui est énorme et du coup les
souvent des policiers mal formés qui
sortent à peine de l'école se retrouvent
sur des terrains et dans des actions où
il faut faire preuve d'expérience et
c'est donc oui il faut il faut surtout
pas penser
que la police et moi je fais pas du tout
partie de ceux qui jettent la pierre en
disant en faisant un amalgame avec ce
qui s'est passé récemment
bien sûr les violences policières ne
sont pas acceptables mais le terme de
violences policières moi ne me convient
pas parce que je considère qu'il donne
il n'est absolument pas adaptée à la
réalité l'immense majorité des policiers
ils ont envie de ils ont à coeur de bien
faire leur travail ils veulent servir
leur pays ils veulent servir leurs
concitoyens mais ils ne peuvent pas le
faire souvent parce que ils n'ont pas
les moyens et le commandement et la
doctrine est souvent défaillante pour la
sécurité il devrait y avoir ni droite ni
gauche c'est ce que vous nous dites
veulent pas vu ni centre ni extrêmes ne
devrions être tous nous devrions être
tous ensemble et lens artères vous nous
dites j'en ai vu des ministres de
l'intérieur depuis 30 ans et rien n'a
changé pouvez vous affirmer le contraire
alors je peux pas vous répondre mais en
tous les cas je peux vous répondre par
une question c'est celle qu'on vous
posez sur twitter justement
faites vous confiance à
jean castex et gérald darmanin pour
restaurer l'autorité de l'état et ça n'a
pas bougé depuis le début du débat animé
puisque vous êtes vous répondez non à 70
%
je propose qu'on arrête là ce débat qui
pourra effectivement continuer qu'on
pourra ré avoir d'autres fois et bien
regarder si on ne va pas avoir à partir
du 14 juillet un nouveau revenant dans
la vie politique française